[Music]
we have a brand new sponsor here at the
show here's their latest commercial yo
I love me some frozen yogurt but I hate
all these cutesy names and weird
toppings Panthro don't they jump the
frozen yogurt
this ain't your girlfriend's yogurt this
is yogurt for rose Barbra's grab a bunch
pail and fill it with sweetener with 12
macho flavors like cool ranch dressing
Red Bull sorbet and nacho cheese both a
better toppings bar chop all the stuff
dudes like mac and cheese hot wings corn
nuts
pastrami eggs scrambled fried and raw
hot pockets they can wrap fish sticks
stay back these guitar picks the mystery
pile and mini pot pies top it all off
with muscle powder get ripped bang
anyway if you break the scales to get
bit by one of our brokers Bay's
outstanding invest of all our burgers is
a hundred percent fat free
the Jays good and it's good for me as a
doctor I cannot recommend excessive
consumption of this so-called deal yeah
that noise with frozen brogre blows and
brogre now with the hundred locations
all at Arizona State University
always do that in his classes
[Applause]
[Music]